what is Chris Hemsworth's personality
fun enthusiastic I think I'm adventurous
I don't love sitting still and and the
fear of boredom certainly keeps me
moving forward and gives me momentum to
try and explore new things what is next
for Chris Hemsworth I'm gonna have some
down time and really enjoy being with my
family and being home and being in one
place and I feel like I've been
unpacking suitcases and packing
suitcases and traveling across the world
for so many you know years now to 10 12
years and it's been incredible and I'm
so so thankful for all of it but I'd
love to just be still for a while now
and inhabit a more simple
slower environment